So now let's look at what
kinds of faults can we have.
We can classify the faults by cause,
and we can have a hardware fault
when the hardware of the system fails
to perform as it was designed to do.
We can have design faults.
For example, software bugs are design
faults, and also some of the hardware
design mistakes,
such as the famous Pantheon FDIV Bug,
where this FDIV instruction was
not implemented correctly, so
if you gave it some
combinations of numbers,
you would get incorrect results,
and it was designed that way.
Then we have operation faults.
For example, operator and user mistakes.
For example, the operator accidentally
tells the system to shut down, and now,
of course, it no longer provides the
service that it's supposed to provide.
And then we can have environmental
faults, such as fire that
burns down the system, power failure,
sabotage of the system,
all things that in the environment may
cause the system to have an error,
ar not perform the service.
Note that these are all false.
Some of them don't result in a failure.
For example, the FDIV bug
doesn't result in a error or
a failure, if you never really use
the wrong combination of numbers for it.
A software bug in a rarely used function
may never result in an actual error.
Operator faults may not cause
a system to actually have an error.
For example if you shut down the system,
but at this time, for example, nobody's
trying to use it to get service from it,
it might not be an actual failure.
And then, we can have a fire but
if we protected our system from fire,
a fire in the system room may
not actually result in an error.
For example we can have a switch
over to another system.
Power failure can be mitigated so
it can be a fault, but
may not result in an error.
For example,
if our battery power supply lasts
long enough to overcome
the power failure, and so on.
So again these are faults
according to their cause.
Any of these faults might result in
errors, and subsequently failures, but
for all of them it is possible
that we get a fault but
not an error or a failure.
We can also classify faults by duration.
For how long do we have
the fault condition?
For example we can
have a permanent fault.
Once we have it,
it doesn't get corrected.
An example of a permanent fault is
when we want to see what's inside
the processor and
now the processor is in four pieces and
we don't know how to
put it back together.
We can have intermittent faults.
They last for a limited duration
of time but they are recurring.
So it's not like we get this type
of fault, and for a while it causes
things to not work fine, but then it
just disappears and never comes back.
This is something like, every couple
of seconds something happens.
A good example of intermittent fault
is when we overclock our system.
It works fine then crashes,
then we reboot it, it works fine,
it crashes, and so on.
So for a while it works fine, but
then the same type of problem recurs.
And then finally we have the transient
faults, which are when it lasts for
while, then just goes away.
A transient fault is for example,
when an alpha particle hits chips, so,
for a while,
it has all sorts of problems, but
then once we reboot it, it's no longer
going to have these problems and
they're not going to occur again, until
much later when something else happens.